have you ever made a terrible mistake
while you were doing someone's hair and
then just tried to cover it up i've
never tried to cover it up but yeah
what's what would be a terrible mistake
to make in the chair the one was my
clippers kind of slipped while i was uh
doing a fade and i got like a little
bald spot on the side of his head but
he didn't care
okay yeah that's nice unfortunate but
that's you know
in the grand scheme of things it's not
that bad how many people work in your
shop it's just me actually and then i
just hire out for like events or
weddings or stuff like that have you
ever hired someone and then they're just
awful they come in and you hate them and
you have to kick them out of your shop
oh yeah oh yeah that's what happens
it's an interesting group of people in
this industry so you get that a lot you
get a lot of like transients that don't
know what they want to do to say it
nicely i'm not trying to be mean but oh
they didn't know what else to do so
that's what they're doing that's kind of
what most three stooges shorts are based
on the three studios are always i mean
they have the truck that has their name
on it and they've shown up at the fancy
society ball but they're always clearly
doing something for the first time and
they have no idea what they're doing and
that includes being a barber being a
plumber being a surgeon they're always
just there giving it a shot for the
first time and then they move on so
you're probably getting people like that
occasionally
you want to throw in on that no i don't
i
gave girly this look
people know about the three students i
know they do it's just a weird i it's an
interesting comparison i mean don't
people have to get their like
cosmetology license you're saying some
people just weren't meant to do it i'm
guessing yeah they get their license but
it was like instead of college because
they didn't want to go to college
right right where's your broadcasting
license sona where's your podcasting
license i have zero likes
where's your broadcast exactly
exactly we're just here we're making it
up
don't joke because this is serious
because you have to have a podcast
yeah we could be arrested
they're gonna they're gonna take our
podcast yeah you guys aren't serious oh
no we are serious totally serious
a lot of stuff i know this isn't cool
not anyone can just have a podcast okay
i know i know you're it is very hard i
didn't know if you had to have a thing
like documentation oh you have to be
born in all right forget it you know
what you know what that sucks now
everyone's going to know i'm stupid no
no there's been a lot of just got better
priorities hey my brother thinks you're
really hot so hey
are you talking to me oh
no i'm talking to sona oh that's nice
now tell us uh nice
sona is married but you never know
things can get a little rocky no i mean
flip your hair to one side
just saying
what is happening what's his name
his name's ryan hi ryan
there is a face but when sono was single
and there was a good-looking waiter
because we spent a lot of time together
we did you would do a sona face
you would angle your face differently
and you would you would act like you
were trying to catch light that wasn't
there what you know in the room can you
do it i mean it was just a lot of like
it was a lot it's it's what it's what
everybody you bat your eyes you just
like laugh a lot at the things they say
and you know what it worked a lot so
that's the stuff you do girly at the
flea market when they have an idea i'm
trying to haggle when they have an
eisenhower poster you've just gotta have
yeah yeah you do a lot of hair flips too
yeah but it's crinkled on the side i
must have that loot oh my god it might
complete my collection you know what in
another life if i was single tell ryan i
said hi i i will tell him
no it's not about you right now it's
about me yeah it's about sona i'd like
to be fair
you're not in on this we'll take you to
the rose bowl swap meet
okay yeah ryan thinks sona's hot and i
have a twin sister who said she was in a
facebook group called i do conan
what what
this was like when she was in college
everybody wants to bang us i know wait
you know
you guys are very bangable
should we change the podcast that
everybody wants to bang us yeah i have
not been included in this so that's okay
don't make it about you just i'm not i'm
i'm an advocate someone will want to
bang you what year was that is this 90s
it was in the 90s that people wanted to
bang me or was it in the 2000s it was in
the 2000s yeah oh
21st century baby are you going to join
this facebook group i was in the group
remember there was start of the group
there was one
there was one woman who looked
suspiciously like me
who was named conan nina he was always
going
anyone else want to bang conan
i know i do
only cool people are banging code
oh i know someone who saw him in the gym
well
let's just say he's built to bed
and then at one point my wig falls off
and everyone's like conan
but your hair becomes better
i don't know if you know how facebook
works yeah are you live broadcast yeah i
don't know i don't know why i'm trying
to make sense of this yeah it's stupid
enough as it is well anyway my
congratulations and and felicitations to
all three people in the
international odd bank conan
[Laughter]
facebook page